Nhưng mà như cầu các ông chỉ ngoài những lộn dung tôi đã nèo trong phát biểu khai mai phủ nghỉ
các ông chỉ cần tập trung, sự đi, một số những trọng tâm, một cái thống chi trị tiêu tục trăm lo,
kiến tạo trong một hình chính quyền địa phương hai cấp hoạt động biểu lực kỳ quả.
Hứ hai là phân định thầm quyền liên thông giữ mà cấp trước tình lĩnh vực,
soát trong lẫn không bỏ trống nhiều vụ.
Nhưng mà phân cấp ở đi cầm k yểm xác, chuyển mạnh xanh hậu kìa m,
tổ chức kìa tỏan loa vụ tình, và xã hữu tư, tài chính công đu phân bỏ thèm kết quả đặc đềm dương của tình biểu phương.
Nhưng xâm sẽ để vị trí về làm quán sản phẩm, nào tạo bắt bộ của chuyên món,
nhìn vụ quán trị giữ liệu.
Tự sống, tổ chức một cửa liên thông số, soát cơ giế xí cho tăng chắc giật của người đứng đầu.
Bây giờ, xong trung kết nối, dân cơ tất đài, ăn xin, tránh nghiệp,
cập dật thử giám thật từ cơ xà ở trung vực.
Muyến tắt xin xuất là điệu phương quyết, điệu phương làm, điệu phương chỉ trách nhiệp,
và gió người, gió việc gió thử hạn, gió người, gió người hạn, gió người người.
Gió trách nhiệp, gió người làm vương, điệu phương thử dân, vì nhé dân phục vụ.
Kép mả sản phẩm, công việc là tức loa cáng nhất,
chính độ và phẩm chất của cám bộ.
Tức sống, bây giờ là gần hết năm 2020,
thời gian từ mai đến lại hội mối muốn không còn nhiều.
Trong khi chúng ta có rất nhiều công việc phở làm,
nhiều chỉ tiêu công tắt, hằng thành trong tháng cuối năm,
trong khi báo lũ, thiệt tay sẽ gà hồ hết cáp, biểu phương.
Gó hội, tư đánh nghĩ, các đồng chỉ, viến chương gân,
khảy nếu gào hư lửa tình thần chắc nghiệp, chức đất đất, với nha dân,
tập trung lấy đào.
Chỉ đào, thực hiện tốt những công việc của đơn vị điều phương mình
đã bảo quan thành các cái chi tiêu được nếu ra trong khi quyết
đại hội lần thứ Mỹ quan của ràng.
Đi quyết phổ cấp ui các cấp,
khảnh chương tổ chức thực hiện các cấp lỗi của nghĩ chúng mình muốn để gó phần
thực hiện công của rại hội lần thứ Mỹ muốn của ràng.